all right mariah welcome back hello
so
lots has happened in your life since the
last time you were here probably four
five six months ago
yes
what to
tell me what's going on
well i have my baby her name is forever
um she's three months now
um currently i don't have her in my
custody because um
obviously i was getting high when i when
i had my baby but i stopped like three
days before i pushed my labor
so that i could come out clean but i
still had marijuana in my system so they
still took her
she's not in foster care exactly but my
foster sister got custody up here so far
right now but i go and i visit her every
two times a week on tuesdays and
wednesdays um for three hours each time
and i'm working on getting her back
right now it's just like it was so hard
because i had like like i said before in
the previous video i had
i was in foster care myself and they
hadn't they haven't closed my case not
until i turned 25 i guess but they don't
even give me any services so i don't get
it but it was easier for them to get in
my my my um
how you say it like my my case like it
was easy for them to open a dcfs case
because i already have one open i guess
so
and you're back working the streets yeah
stay in the room every day i don't work
as much like you know i try not to work
the streets actually i do most of the
internet you know i kind of i try to go
back on the streets and i just it's not
for me like i got scared i don't know
how scared you know it's so much
different it's different it's changed
you know
well maybe you're becoming aware of how
dangerous it is yeah
especially now that you're a mother
you have to be responsible for your
child though right this is your first
yeah yeah
are you working with a pimper without
now no
um currently i actually like i have a
boyfriend right now but
it's so difficult like it's hard to have
a boyfriend after coming like you know
like the life the street life you know
like it's very hard especially because
you don't like me to work you know
so but
i try you know i try to do it as less as
possible but it's not it's hard yeah
it's not the same anymore you're not
saving money i assume
not really i pay for room every day like
like i just got kicked out of my room
because they're remodeling like and it
was actually pretty cool room you know
like they weren't charging me that much
every day but
you know like now i gotta like all my
stuff is like somewhere in the basket
just sitting there
and uh
you're using crystal meth
yeah i slowed down like i said i pushed
my labor
for two days so that i could make sure i
was cleaning off from it like you know
which i was cleaning off of meth but i
still had marijuana in my system
and um
i slowed down but i kind of you know
like since i had my baby and they took
her
i still smoke i ain't gonna lie like you
know like i still get high like you know
it helps me like least at least at the
moment like
get away from reality you know
do all the pressures of everything that
is on your shoulders right now get to
you yeah it's got you right
do you have any family to help you no
nobody i don't have no family no one to
rely on
thank god like i got in contact with my
sister kind of and it's not even that
easy with her like to get my baby but
because she don't contact me at all like
she don't tell me nothing
and what are your plans now
honestly i really don't know right now
it's hard like you know
i'm kind of losing faith a little bit
like it seems like once i get all right
like something happens to where like you
know
it just like throws me off like you know
it's going to be hard to get ahead
of this position surviving every day
how does it affect you emotionally i'm
sure
depressing
very
like
especially since i don't have my baby
you know
like i like in the beginning i really
didn't want her like i didn't want no
kids honestly but
it was too late for me to like you know
i don't believe in abortions like i said
everybody deserves a chance so
i couldn't have an abortion and
i you know like
i wonder of course i want her like i
grew to love her like i carried her for
nine months like i go see her i make
effort like you know
but it's not easy like you know right
now they want me to find a spot a stable
spot
i still haven't got my id like it's
difficult i'm waiting on i actually went
to the
um secure social security office though
and like
made an effort to get my social security
number card or whatever and now i'm just
waiting on it to come so i could try to
get my birth certificate but it's so
hard like i've been waiting for two
weeks already
and the father of the child do you know
no that makes it hard too
it's all on you now
yeah
what are you looking at your life now
how old do you know 24 24 looking back
at your life what do you wish would have
been different
it might change your situation today
honestly i really don't know like i
never really think about it like that
because i just think of it like
everything that i've done so far has
made me know
because it's not like i could go back
and change it really honestly so i just
try not to too much you know
dear friends
yeah i have a few friends
are they in similar situations
are they in similar situations yeah like
honestly yeah
i've been in the streets my whole life
so i don't know too many like you know
productive people i guess you could say
all my friends are either
in the same boat as me or probably a
little worse or something you know so
it's not like
the most i could probably go to them for
is like kind of advice you get you know
like which is it helps a lot it does
but then again i don't even like talking
to people a lot so like as far as like
my personal business so it's like just
maybe one or two
you had a daughter
yeah i had a daughter she's uh
three months ago three months
staying with your sister my sister my
foster sister
oh it's a foster sister yeah i don't
have no siblings
i don't know
and you're really on your own aren't you
yeah anything you went through anything
that's happened
um either on the streets or anywhere
else
honestly
at the moment no because i like i said i
haven't really been working the streets
i
i kind of get dressed to go out and then
i don't know i kind of chicken up a
little bit you can say
i get a little scared i guess
then i don't make it out there
the one time i did try like you know i
got chased and i just was like you know
what uh i think i'm i'm i must i'm just
give it a do you think that's just your
maternal instinct huh it's your
your mother instincts
honestly i don't know like now since i
have my baby i look at my life more
importantly yeah that's true
because i have something to live for now
or someone to live for now like you know
but
i don't feel so successful but hey
how much do you think the drug uses
huh how much do you think the crystal
meth use is causing a problem for you
keeping you from
getting off the streets or anything like
that
well
honestly speaking i know it's it's it's
it's like it's not helping honestly i
know but it just helps me get away from
reality at most at the moment you know
like
it's harder to like cope and deal with
life without it i guess
yeah
do you have do you have hope of
i do have hope yeah i do of course i do
like you know
but
at times in my you know my faith kind of
weakens a little bit because of whether
it's my situation obviously you know
what not but
i don't know like you know i do have
hope though
[Music]
yeah i've signed up for some housing
programs but that's just it's not like
you know it's kind of it's very
difficult like you know it's
it's like you got to be like i don't
know what it is like i wish i could
figure it out like to figure out how
these people get
where it helps so fast but
i don't know
i've been calling all these places like
i don't know
they want me to do classes i started
doing a few of my classes like you know
but
the last time i was supposed to go to
one of my classes like i didn't have a
room then the prior night so it was like
i didn't sleep so i couldn't make it to
like my class the next day and i haven't
been since that day
all right mariah thank you so much for
sharing your story and i wish you your
baby the best of luck i hope you get her
back
thank you thank you very much
you